hallo meine lieben freunde willkommen
zur ersten folge von einem neuen format
in denen ich probiere mich zu einer
rolex hoch zu handeln
[Musik]
rolex trader wie größte serie dies aus
meinem kanal gab über zwölf folgen haben
wir gemacht indem wir immer wieder
versucht haben durch kleine tricks
irgendwelche hacks oder auch einfach
viel arbeit um gute ideen genug geld
zusammen zu sammeln um eine rolex kaufen
zu können und das hat jetzt tatsächlich
geklappt ich habe eine rote kaufte ich
habe sie auch schon bezahlt wir sind auf
dem weg nach düsseldorf um sie bei wem
anders als marc gebauer abzuholen aber
nicht für mich sondern für jemand von
euch es ist völlig verrückt das war mein
absolutes traum format ich konnte machen
was mich wirklich interessiert hat also
geld verdienen nicht des geldes wegen
sondern weil ich spaß daran habe kleine
wege um tricks zu finden wie man an geld
kommen kann darunter waren sachen wie
liebe geld das war eine coole idee
deshalb das funktioniert endeffekt habe
ich das geld nicht bekommen aber genau
solche sachen erfüllen mich wirklich
also das ist kein witz das macht mich
einfach glücklich an solchen sachen zu
arbeiten crypto hebeln aktien hebeln
aktien kaufen und in online shop für
vintage klamotten aufzuziehen mich
wissen was mich erwartet dann aber nur
coole werbung schneiden und eine website
aufziehen auf der tatsächlich leute
sachen gekauft haben das ist ziemlich
ziemlich verrückt und ich blicke gerne
auf all diese videos zurück weil ich
weiß wie viel spaß gemacht hat und weil
das wegweisend für mich und meinen
youtube kanal war und eine menge leute
von euch sind darüber auf meinen kanal
gekommen dann bin ich sehr glücklich
drüber und genau das ist der grund warum
ich mich dazu entschieden habt die rolex
nicht selber zu behalten sondern die an
jemanden von euch zu geben es gibt
allerdings einen kleinen twist an der
sache ich verschenkt die rolex nicht
einfach so an irgendwem sondern wir
haben uns was ziemlich krass überlegt
und zwar verlor sich die eu nicht
alleine sondern gemeinsam mit heimischen
anbieter mit dem ich vorher schon öfter
zusammengearbeitet habe bei dem ihr die
möglichkeit habt anteile von kollekte
bis zu kaufen sei es rein kunst autos
oder eben im prinzip jede art von
sammlerstücken die kümmern sich darum
dass die sicher gelagert werden und ihr
könnt ganz easy über der band hält ich
bin wirklich riesen fan von deren
angebot und habe selber dort geld
investiert ich finde das mega geil und
freue mich deswegen dass sie mich dabei
unterstützen aber ihr gewinnt die rolex
nicht einfach so sondern immer es etwas
dafür tut ladet euch jetzt die teile des
herunter und suchte über die nächsten
fünf tage immer wieder hinweise die am
ende der fünf tage einen kompletten
gewinner sonst ja aber natürlich bekommt
ihr trotzdem noch 10 euro startguthaben
als neukunden und könnt euch damit einen
kostenlosen anteil eines es sicher
irgendwann können sich überall in der
app verstecken also haltet eure augen
offen ist sind immer wieder wörter so
viel kann ich schon sagen die am ende
eben diesen einen satz ergeben der satz
ergibt auch sinn also wenn am ende bei
euch irgendein satz raus kommt der
keinen sinn macht dann ist es vermutlich
nicht der richtige sagt von heute
mittwoch bis sonntag kommen also jeden
tag hinweise die am ende einen satz aus
fünf wörtern ag ihr könnt also auch noch
mitmachen wenn ihr das video jetzt nicht
am upload tag dem mittwoch sehen sondern
donnerstag freitag samstag oder sogar
sonntag noch am sonntag dem 23 000 ist
dann aber wirklich schluss und es gibt
keine möglichkeit mehr teilzunehmen denn
am montag gilt ist für euch den
richtigen satz in meiner investoren
antwort fällt einzutragen und von diesen
leuten die dann den antworten richtig
eingetragen haben werden zehn leute von
euch nach köln eingeladen um mit mir in
einem final video um die rolex zu
spielen das wird richtig fett wir haben
uns kranke sachen überlegt ladet euch
die app über den ersten blick eher video
beschreibungen runter nehmen teilt und
nutzt eure chance eine rolex zu bin ich
bin richtig dankbar dass tylers mich bei
diesem video und auch beim nächsten bei
dem absolut riesigen final video wieder
unterstützt das ist ziemlich cool ich
liebe deren service und bin sehr dankbar
dass wir da zusammengefunden jetzt viel
spaß weiter mit dem video wir fahren zum
marc gebauer und finden heraus um welche
rolex es geht ihr könnt euch ja denken
es ging die wirklich um die roll ist es
ging darum ein festes ziel zu haben auf
das man hinarbeitet gegen eine grenze zu
haben an der ab der man weiß dass das
projekt vielleicht auch einfach ein ende
nehmen kann und weil es einfach ein
krasses goal ist sowas zu erreichen
nicht weil es mir super wichtig ist
jetzt eine rolex am arm zu tragen das
ist trotz alledem einfach sehr emotional
für mich der tag heute war ich über den
prozess irgendwie auch an diesem auto
gekommen bin jetzt kann ich mit meinem
eigenen auto was ich mir darüber so ein
bisschen finanzieren konnte in eine
andere stadt fahren und eine rolex
kaufen die ich an einen von euch
verschenken das erfüllt mich wirklich
kraft und ich bin richtig happy das ist
nur ein symbol aber ein ziemlich cool
wir sind angekommen bei wem anders als
marc gebauer hätte ich diese uhr kaufen
sollen und was das für eine ist welche
uhr ich an euch verschenken möchte das
schauen wir uns jetzt gemeinsam
ja
ja hier ist etwas sehr besonderes drin
und zwar wir haben hier das fest laufen
es ist wir vielleicht schon erahnen
könnt eine data ist von der marke rolex
eine vintage stellt just mit einer weiß
kontinente und dem jubiläum band also
das ist ein silbernes zifferblatt wir
haben hier ein datum automatikwerk aus
stahl die us extrem widerstandsfähig und
in einer konkurrenzlosen preis klasse
also das ist wirklich so eine uhr wenn
man damit anfängt also nicht weil ich ja
heute auch 36 millimeter an ich finde
die die größte allgemeinen nimmt immer
mehr zu auch zum beispiel nico also in
scope hat auch 37 mm hatte mal eine
zeitlang sehr große ohren jetzt ist
wieder zurückgegangen und ja derjenige
der diese ruhe bekommen wird kann sich
selber sehr sehr freuen ist es wirklich
etwas für die ewigkeit und wenn man
darauf gut aufpasst ja dann hält sie für
ein leben lang es richtig gut ich habe
mich auch genau deswegen für diese größe
entschieden weil ich nicht wusste
willkommen zum elbe kommt ein junger und
das ist eine größe die von allen
irgendwie gleich gut getragen werden
kann und ich habe autos gefühl dass die
schönen unauffällig ist und einfach ein
wunderschönes modell besonders schön
wenn das bei irgendjemandem von euch am
abend dann getragen werden kann ja was
soll ich sagen es ist ein absoluter
traum hier noch einmal vielen dank an
jeden einzelnen der das möglich gemacht
hat indem er die videos geguckt hat
support hat und allgemeinem ich auf
dieser reise begleitet hat vielen vielen
dank jetzt gibt es für euch allerdings
eine sache zu tun ladet euch die app
unternimmt an dem gewinnspiel teil und
sei möglicherweise in dem großen finale
video dabei ich freue mich wenn möglich
wieder leute mitmachen und wir daraus
ein richtig dickes ding machen können
allgemein ihr habt vielleicht in der
letzten woche merkt es kam kein video
wie ein videos kam warst du ein bisschen
lover video wir sind gerade komplett
2022 haben durch planen und wird fitter
denn je also seid euch sicher wenn ihr
am wenigsten von uns hört machen wir am
meisten hinter mir ihr seht ihr die
allerletzten kartons die klamotten mäßig
angekommen sind es kommt der doku es
kommen riesige projekte wo wir überall
hin
sind es kommen aufwändige projekte es
wird richtig krass also vielen dank
vergesst es den kanal zu abonnieren
klasse millionen leichter und ladet euch
die app runter macht es gut wir sehen
uns am donnerstag wieder
[Musik]